tonight China is pushing back against
growing US intelligence that points to
Wuhan and a mistake in the lab there
that was studying the virus in bats that
may have led to this global pandemic the
focus is on an infected worker who
spread it to her partner she may be the
patient zero that the world has been
looking for according to this latest
intelligence and reports joining me now
Republican Senator Marco Rubio of
Florida member of the Foreign Relations
Committee senator always good to see you
thank you for being here tonight how
much credibility do you give this
emerging story well I think this one
worth paying attention to it would be a
dramatic earth-shattering revelation if
in fact it turns out to be the case and
that would be the case for two reasons
number one is one thing that someone
became infected at a lab and they
infected some other people that's
concerning that the safety standards
there are not high but another thing
completely is that a government when
they learn of it would actively attempt
to cover it up as they have if that's
the case you know from the very
beginning of this crisis the Chinese
have been less than transparent and you
know if something like that happened in
the United States there would be because
we are an open society and a democracy
there would be almost immediate
accountability and a revelation about it
at some point and there would be a big
price to pay for covering something like
that out both legally and politically so
I think there's going to be it'll be a
tremendous global scandal one of the
most outrageous things that has happened
in the modern history of the world of
that word to turn out to be true so
what's the next step I mean you know I
think we talked so much about holding
China accountable the president was
pretty forceful on this in a very sort
of subtle way if you can do both of
those things at once he said people
should have told us people should have
told us he said that several times and
that's a pretty I think pretty clear
message that he is not liking what he's
hearing about this you know it's
reminiscent somewhat of Chernobyl which
was obviously that accident a while back
and ironically that makes theory fear
recently about it and the way the Soviet
government reacted to that and so it's
if this has turned out to be the case
it's very reminiscent of that you're
already seeing
some people in Africa in poor countries
saying that China should be contributing
to some sort of global fund to help pay
reparations for what they have gone
through but I think there'll be some
tough conversations throughout the world
about what needs to be done in regards
to this but I think no matter what at
this point no matter what you may be
reading some of the articles out there
by some of these people who think they
know it all here's the truth
China's reputation globally has already
been badly damaged there are plenty of
countries out there that know exactly
how China mishandled this irrespective
of whether this came out of that lab or
not they're not out there talking about
it because their economies are not big
enough to take China on directly but the
damage that China has suffered to its
perception around the world is in many
ways irreparable so I guess the question
becomes you know we hear a lot of
outrage we hear people say that they
don't like the fact that all of our
antibiotics most of them are made in
China that we need to I know you've
worked on this to bring back the
production of these drugs at home and I
think the American people kind of want
to know when they're gonna see all that
actually happened because we hear the
president talk about the trade deal and
how important the trade deal is and that
he wants to keep that going I mean how
do you how can we have a relationship
with this country if this is true yeah
you know over a year ago I released a
report from the Small Business Committee
called made in China 2025 and the plan
to reinvigorate America's industry and
the basic premise of it was there are
some things that even if they are
cheaper to make somewhere else we have
to be able to make in our own country
for our own security thank God for the
American farmer thank God we didn't
outsource that and and I think um seeing
some of those things exposed now from
little swabs nasal swabs that we need
for the tests the personal protective
equipment to the components that go into
a ventilator and then you keep going all
the way to rare earth minerals which are
critical for almost all of high tech
that we are overly the world is overly
dependent on China and our supply chain
and yes it's cheaper to do those things
over there but we cannot afford from an
economic and national security
standpoint but not have the industrial
capacity to do things not to mention the
jobs that come with it so that's
something you should have been looking
at already
I think this crisis will only accelerate
it I think you got a lot of agreement on
that if it turns out that they sat on
this for 16
didn't tell anyone held a huge
international festival knowing this in
Wuhan and then let people fly all over
the world afterwards that as you say is
going to be an international scandal of
epic proportion when you look at what
has happened to so many people around
this world and still happening in some
of the developing nations in a way
that's gonna be very very difficult for
them senator Rubio thank you always good
to thank you stay safe